I think there's what comes under this we
look at differentiation and then we have
a think about trying to solve equations
and graph them and the tools that make
that easier okay so for instance one of
the things that comes out of this is
example what else comes out as you
remember your our advanced tree topic
last year and a bookmark on it what else
came under this before sorry
yeah before invest rating actually we
dealt with industry one its own though
if we go get to that afterwards I just
think about the review stuff so there's
also a tea results there's general
solution now even though that's kind of
review we're going to look at some
slightly new stuff on agenda solution
because there are questions in the Jan's
I've seen also the program where it's
like okay you're gonna graft okay tell
me where all the stationary points are
all of them right not within a specific
domain so since you're asking for all of
them you need to go to general solution
for that right it's not really that much
harder you're just finding the a general
solution for this so you can do with
that right but because it's stationary
points it looks something different and
you might not be familiar
okay anyway we'll get to those and then
after this we saw of the more newer
stuff it does relate to in verse three
so we look at the integration results
things that functions you integrate and
it gets you to an inverse trig function
okay or integration where you have to
use a substitution and the substitution
is a trigonometric result something
related to that
okay so that's where we headed over the
next week or so so just three of you
where we're gonna start here and if you
came in and got the sheet that was on
the front desk you'll see so just to get
your heads back in the right space maybe
you can put yourself together a little
table and let's see if we can remember
these results thinking about the six
main
she functions right 6 main ones so you
have a three basic ones and then you've
got their reciprocals
so your basic ones are here and we've
done these to death by now
right so you can tell me off the top of
your head derivative for sign is because
derivative for cos minus sign through
different an thanks X Squared's okay so
they're all fine right but then when you
get to the reciprocals I know they come
up less often but they come up often
enough that it's worth actually
remembering rather than going back to
chain rule the question rule that kind
of thing sir sine cos tan in order
they're reciprocals our third letter for
each reciprocal function so Kosek sick
and cot
okay now how do you remember these the
way I remember them is with these cosec
and SEC ones right their derivatives
power these two functions multiplied by
extra stuff if you remember those so we
couchette I'm gonna start by writing
Kozak and then it's multiplied by
something else this is a remember it
pairs up with Claude it pairs I meant
Claude okay
however once you if you do take you know
sine x to the -1 and you do chain rule
you end up with a minus sign at the
front okay so don't forget that one it's
sort of like sine goes to positive cos x
but when you take the reciprocal it
becomes a negative okay lots of things
to confuse with anyway when I take my
other one sick again I start with sick
and then I add another theme it's sort
of like your opposite of this right so
instead of cough I'm gonna add on 10 ok
so there's it now 10x you differentiate
you get six squared okay so when you
take the reciprocal what would you
expect to get cosine squared it's sort
of like um these are kind of like
partners if you like so cut and Kousaka
always go together you can see that
yeah and tan and sick always go together
so there's kind of a symmetry to it so
even though I actually have a lot of
trouble if you give me one without any
context I have trouble remembering which
one it is but when I have all six there
it's kinda like oh I can see which one's
match up okay